thanks to skillshare for helping support
this episode
hey crazies 107 years ago albert
einstein and david hilbert published
general relativity it's the best model
of gravity we have
but university courses on it are
surprisingly difficult to find
my master's program didn't offer one so
i had to teach myself
i had to read through all sorts of books
some were better than others
today i want to share my experience with
you in the hopes that it'll save you a
little time and stress
[Music]
what's your experience smartypants
okay that's a fair question i have a
master's degree in physics i know you
mean well when you call me doctor but
you really shouldn't
for those unfamiliar with academia the
only difference between a master and a
phd is that a phd knows a lot more than
others about a very very very niche
topic and they're certified by the
university in that niche topic
but that doesn't mean that masters don't
specialize we do
also it's not like we stop learning when
our degree is finished
my journey into general relativity began
with my master's thesis
the question i was trying to answer was
whether or not applying general
relativity to white dwarf stars made a
noticeable difference in their upper
mass limit the answer was yes but not as
much as i was expecting a negative
result is still a result anyway this
interest in gr continued after i got my
degree
one of my special interests is cosmology
the physics of cosmic scales it's a
long-term obsession
gr is vitally important for that topic
so i had motivation to learn everything
i could
that involved a lot of reading and a lot
of pondering
so where do we start
well any deep journey into general
relativity should start with special
relativity the best book i've ever seen
covering this is special relativity for
beginners a textbook for undergraduates
jurgen jurgen jurgen friend it's german
you know they're gonna get on me you
know it
you're confront
droin
freund okay jurgen freund a textbook for
undergraduates by jurgen freund
jurgen freund
it might not be particularly colorful or
look very exciting but it teaches you
how to draw space-time diagrams
granted none of those diagrams include
curve space time like you'd see in gr
but you've got to walk before you can
run as they say
space-time diagrams are important tools
for visualizing relativity if you know
how to use them they can help you avoid
your own biases
now i realize not everyone can just drop
a load of money on books and you can't
always find books like these in your
local library
there are some free resources available
the findman lectures are a decent place
to go for special relativity or frankly
anything
as you can see i have the hard copies in
my personal library but caltech made
them all available online for free link
in the dooblydoo
anyway richard feynman was one of the
greatest teachers of the last century
his casual style and his emphasis on
intuition are immortalized in these
books
i've referenced them while producing
many of my videos they're a valuable
resource
here are the chapters relevant to
special relativity feel free to pause
and jot them down or screen cap or
whatever
unfortunately the fineman lectures don't
come with practice problems and practice
is where the real learning begins that's
why it's better to have at least a few
textbooks like freund
that's why it's better to have at least
a few textbooks like freund somewhere in
your process
what about wikipedia and youtube
when i was getting my degrees online
educational video wasn't a thing and
wikipedia was a very new and terribly
untrustworthy thing
but that doesn't mean they aren't useful
wikipedia is big on citations these days
sources are listed at the bottom of the
page
those are the real power of that website
but try to limit yourself to the
scientific papers
as for online video there are some great
options for special relativity
i have a playlist on it though some of
those videos are old and kind of
embarrassing minutephysics also has a
great playlist where he actually built a
spacetime diagram toy unfortunately
these have the same problem that the
fineman lectures do no practice problems
plus it's difficult to know who to trust
credentials can help but you don't need
credentials to be a good science
communicator
checking for sources in the video
description is a good first step if you
stumble onto an educational youtube
channel and their entire brand is
defined in opposition to everyone else
you should at least be a little
skeptical
just a suggestion
crash course has a playlist called
navigating digital information if you
need more help with this
talk about general relativity already
okay okay next up we have this very
popular book
gravity an introduction to einstein's
general relativity by james hardell part
one in this book is just a review of
special relativity it might help you get
used to hardl's notation but you can
skip it if you want
part two is what makes this book so
popular it's lighter on the math in
favor of intuition i mean as light as
you can go on the math in gr
hartl tries to focus more on space-time
infinitesimals in part two and includes
space-time diagrams whenever possible
this exposes the reader to some common
patterns we see in general relativity
you know before we get into the heavy
math of tensors
tensors and four-dimensional vectors
aren't really covered until part three
the upside to that is that the reader
isn't scared away the downside is
einstein's equation isn't covered until
you're almost at the end of the book
which seems silly to me
overall hurdle is a good place to start
on the fundamentals of gr but you should
be wary of the practical applications of
this book
back when i was going through my grad
work i noticed that this graph didn't
match these equations
i actually emailed the author and then
he told me that the graph was made by
somebody else at a different school
just because it's in a book it doesn't
mean it's correct
if writing my own book has taught me
anything it's that authors are not
infallible thankfully early readers of
the ebook version caught most of my
mistakes and i was able to fix them
before releasing the hard copy
but that's enough shameless
self-promotion for one video
the next book on our list is this one
space time in geometry by sean carroll
yes that's sean carroll
like usual this book begins with a
review of special relativity but don't
skip chapter one
this review chapter is written as a
special case of general relativity
tensors are introduced almost
immediately you need to read it
this approach is more rigorous but it
could easily scare away anyone new to gr
that's why you should read and work
through the practice problems and hurdle
first
when you finally get to the carol book
it hopefully won't feel so overwhelming
the rigor in here will also fill in many
of the gaps left in hurdle it's even a
good reference text as you can see from
the wear and tear on my copy
sean carroll has also made some
resources available for free online
there's a 24-page no-nonsense
introduction available on his own
website and 238 pages of lecture notes
from a first course on gr available on
archive.org links in the dooblydoo
both of which are written in the same
style as this book
beyond that there are really only two
more books in a relativist library
general relativity by wald and
gravitation by misner thorne and wheeler
i never would have gotten through my
master's thesis without the wall book
it's a textbook so it's organized in a
way that makes sense to read from front
to back unfortunately it does lean
heavily into the math without asking
forgiveness but that means it's going to
cover a lot of the nuance in gr
walled is also a place you want to go
for practical applications like white
dwarfs black holes and cosmology it
corrected a lot of those application
issues i found in hartle which is odd
because hurdle referenced wald
gravitation is a completely different
story also known as the big black book
it's the ultimate compendium for general
relativity
but it is not a textbook it is a
reference only this book is not meant to
be read front to back it's almost 1300
pages the way this book was written and
organized lend more to research than
learning it not only has a standard
index but also lists of all tables
figures and boxes within the book the
text formatting makes important
information pop off the page for easy
discovery this is a book you use when
you need to find specific information
it's not a book where you learn the
basics
it's a beast
but remember you need to go beyond the
reading it's really easy to read a book
and think you understand not realizing
there are holes in that understanding
do the problems at the end of each
chapter in the textbooks i've mentioned
practice is key you might not retain it
otherwise you could also try to explain
it to someone else and have them ask you
questions write down the questions you
couldn't answer and then look for those
answers
it seems like a lot of work
yeah general relativity is a lot of work
can i just watch some youtube videos
okay if you absolutely must have the
info in video form and you want more
than just a passing understanding you're
gonna need to go beyond edutainment
not even my videos are enough
you need to be watching pure education
content like dr physics a's playlist on
special and general relativity or
eigenchris's multiple playlists on
tensors links in the dooblydoo but you
need to think of them like tutorials
rather than lectures if you want to
retain the material work through it
yourself
you're not just absorbing knowledge
you're learning a new skill
kinda like the ones you can learn on
skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for anyone who wants to explore
their creativity or learn new skills
to help me produce this video i work
through a class by marquez brownlee in
youtube success script shoot and edit
with mkbhd he explains his entire
process from pre to post-production
of course i've been doing this for a
while so i'd already figured out some of
his suggestions but this video was going
to involve camera shots that were a bit
outside my wheelhouse so it was helpful
to see how much planning went into his
shots
if video production isn't your thing
skillshare also has classes on
photography animation productivity and
more you should be able to find classes
that will match your goals and interests
if this sounds like something you might
be interested in check out skillshare
the first 1000 people to use my special
link will get a one month free trial
it'll also let skillshare know you heard
about them from me which helps out the
channel
so was this kind of video helpful for
you let us know in the comments
thanks for liking and sharing this video
a special thanks goes out to my patreon
patrons and youtube members like joseph
salamoni who's been pledging at the
einsteinium level for almost a year and
a half thanks so much for your support
don't forget to subscribe if you'd like
to keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
why doesn't the distance between the
ships contract because we defined the
scenario that way
i defined acceleration in the same
fashion as the distance is maintained
from the inertial observer's point of
view if it's not maintained in your
mental picture then we're talking about
two different scenarios anyway thanks
for watching